hallo ihr lieben heute gibt es ein
richtig sommerlich ist es her bevor ich
anfange und eben die ganze die auf meine
bucket ich habe meine weisheitszähne
raus bekommen und deswegen ist jetzt ein
bisschen dicker aber das rezept wollte
ich euch trotzdem unbedingt noch zeigen
so lange das wetter so schön ist wenn
das das perfekte sommer rezept ich zeige
euch hier auch richtig tolle tipps und
tricks und anschließend eine richtig
schöne festliche dekoration für die
joghurt bombe benötigen wir kalte
schlagsahne joghurt eine bio zitrone
zucker und etwas vanille zucker
jetzt schlage ich zuallererst meine
kalte schlagsahne steife ich nämlich die
küchenmaschine ihr könnt eure
handrührgerät benutzen wichtig ist nur
kein sonne stand mittel also sahnesteif
hat die absolut nicht zu suchen
die konsistenz wie bekommen wir später
das erkläre ich euch nur und die schlage
ich jetzt ganz einfach steifen
[Musik]
die sahne habe ich jetzt steif
geschlagen und jetzt geht es weiter mit
dem joghurt hieß es egal ob wir
fettarmen joghurt nimmt ich habe hier
1,5 prozentigen ob ihr fett gehaltvollen
dem mit 10 prozent ist vollkommen egal
was auch mein persönlicher tipp ist auch
ganz lecker vielleicht hatte ja so ein
lieblingsort mit geschmack da gibt es ja
auch ganz viele leckere varianten den
könnt ihr hier auch an der stelle gerne
verwenden und da gebe ich jetzt
zuallererst den abrieb meiner bio
zitrone rein
[Musik]
falls ihr keine bio zitrone da habt dann
könnt ihr das auch weglassen das ist
auch kein problem aber es schmeckt ein
bisschen frischer und jetzt gebe ich
noch einen spritzer zitronensaft rein
als nächstes gebe ich zu ihr mutmasste
zucker und vanillezucker an der stelle
könnt ihr auch wandel extrakt mit
reinnehmen tut man da eingefallen nimmt
kein vanillinzucker denn der hat mit der
echten vanille gar nichts zu tun
das gebe ich jetzt noch mit rhein und
ruhr das gut um
[Musik]
so der joghurt teil ist fertig jetzt
haben wir nur noch unsere steif
geschlagene sahne unter und dann geht's
weiter
[Musik]
als nächstes benötigen wir drei weitere
utensilien zum einen ein feines haar sie
dazu sage ich euch gleich noch was
außerdem eine ausreichend große schüssel
wo das hab' ich drauf hast und zum
anderen ein dünnes baumwolltuch das habe
ich per hand gewaschen das heißt macht
das nicht so dass er später auch der
weichspüler geschmack oder die mitte von
beispiel joghurt bombe sind das absolut
nicht empfehlenswert zum h sieg wollte
ich euch noch sagen hier kommt auch ganz
auf die größe an
ich schreibe euch in die info box welche
größe für welche mengenangabe ausreicht
ich habe ziemlich groß ist das hat einen
durchmesser von 25 cm
normal sind so 18 19 cm schreibe euch
aber die genauen mengenangaben unten in
die infobox und noch ein kleiner tipp
ist kann ja mal passieren dass sh sie so
ein bisschen verborgen ist spüren oder
durch lagern dort drauf dass das richtig
schön rund ist und dann könnt ihr damit
anfangen und jetzt gehen wir unser
baumwolltuch in unser hasi und zwar so
dass möglichst wenige risse entstehen
also mit christa meine ich einfach hier
an der seite ihr könnt nicht vermeiden
dass ihr halt diese risse später
entstehen aber dafür ist unsere gut
bombe ja später schön dekoriert mit den
früchten sieht man das auch nicht aber
ihr könnt von vornherein hat schon so
ein bisschen vermeiden
noch ein kleiner tipp an alle die jetzt
sagen ich hab mir gerade keinen
baumwolltuch was ich jetzt dafür
benutzen kann könnte auch ganz einfach
küchenrolle nehmen macht euch keine
sorgen das bleibt nichts dran kleben wir
können es auch ganz einfach abziehen
aber dann hat ja diese prägung drin da
sie nach dem was dem muster einer
küchenrolle hat so muss das dann auch
eure joghurt bombe
[Musik]
jetzt streiche ich das ganze noch so
ganz leicht glaubt an der oberfläche und
ganz wichtig ist dass in dieser joghurt
bombe eben kein sahne stand mit
irgendwas zu suchen hat das macht
überhaupt keinen sinn denn was gleich im
kühlschrank passiert ist folgendes die
ganze flüssigkeit geht raus aus mir
kunden aus der saane und dadurch
entsteht diese muss artige konsistent
und deswegen braucht ihr hier weder
sahnesteif noch schnee mit ihr noch
sonst irgendwas wichtig ist nur die kühe
zeit gibt es die einhalten mindestens
zwölf stunden oder über nacht ganz wie
ihr möchtet so ich hab das ganze jetzt
natürlich und vorbereitet damit ich
nicht so lange warten muss und hier
sehen wir jetzt unsere jungen bombe die
es richtig schön fest geworden genauso
wie sie sein soll
die ganze flüssigkeit wurde hier
aufgefangen und das ist jetzt machen ist
einfach einen schönen großen teller
nehmen sie diesen großen weißen genommen
und dann das ganze einfach einfach mal
umstürzen
[Musik]
die bombe habe ich jetzt bis zur
weiterverarbeitung in den kühlschrank
gegeben wir machen jetzt zuallererst
hintertür ihr fertig das benutzen wir
gleich als bett für unsere leckeren
früchte und dann bereiten wir unsere
früchte vor für das himbeer püree
benötigen wir tiefkühlen werden zum
süßen etwas puderzucker kristallzucker
ist nicht so sehr geeignet weil sich die
zuckerkristalle nicht so schnell
auflösen und für die konsistenz noch
etwas wasser
[Musik]
das hemme paris auch schon fertig ich
gebe da gerne immer ein bisschen mehr
wasser rein damit so ein bisschen
dünnflüssiger ist und so eine fließende
konsistenz hat hin werde nämlich aus dem
grund weil sie nach den kurieren sondern
richtig schöne sagte farbe haben anders
als bei erdbeeren zum beispiel die sind
meiner meinung nach nach dem für ihn so
ein bisschen besser deswegen greife ich
immer gerne zur tiefe hin mehr zurück
[Musik]
meine früchte stehen bereit hier habe
ich kiwis in scheiben geschnitten
außerdem orangen und grapefruit die habe
ich erst halbiert und dann in scheiben
geschnitten hier habe ich schöne
heidelbeeren halbierte erdbeeren mini
bananen außerdem johannisbeeren und
kirchen die kirchen die habe ich aus dem
garten falls ihr die möglichkeit habt
generell früchte aus dem garten zu holen
dann tut darf denn nichts ist besser als
das
[Musik]
außerdem habe ich hier noch eine ananas
da habe ich einmal das fleisch in kleine
würfel geschnitten und das tier das
dürft ihr nicht wegwerfen den kopf der
anderen nach dem benutzen wir später
nämlich noch als deko und zu guter letzt
habe ich hier noch verschiedenfarbige
weintrauben
ich habe meine joghurt aus dem
kühlschrank geholt und jetzt kommt der
spastik zeit überhaupt jetzt wird das
ganze richtig schön festlich dekoriert
dafür gebe ich zu allererstes hinter
parry an die seite und dann kommen die
früchte darauf wird zeige ich euch meine
variante der deko wenn es euch gefällt
könnte das ganz genauso machen
[Musik]
und so ist die joghurt bombe schon
richtig beeindruckend weil sie so voller
früchte ist und einfach so monströs
aussehen und das sollte sie auch das
team so ein richtig festlich ist bisher
was aber total leicht schmeckt ich finde
wenn ihr jetzt noch was besonderes haben
möchtet dann gibt er den kopf dieser
ananas noch auf die rohrbombe ich habe
jetzt zu zum stabilisieren noch zwei
schaftlich spieße reingetan bisschen
gekürzte sind ein bisschen stabiler als
die ganz normalen zahnstocher und die
gibt es dann einfach oben drauf
[Musik]
ich weiß schon wie es schmeckt aber ich
probiere gerne noch mal ich habe eine
frage wer von euch ja schon mal ein
flugzeug am fenster platz und hat sich
so die wolken anderen gucken dachte so
fängt man an zu philosophieren
man denkt man sich doch so die wolken
wohl schmecken würden genauso wie genau
so schmecken wolken ich sag's euch das
schmeckt so leicht so lecker genau
richtig ok ich komme zum ende
ich hoffe dass euch meine bäume gefallen
hat freue mich wenn ihr sie vielleicht
nach macht die genauen mengenangaben und
weitere tipps und tricks und nehme
infobox und dann freue ich mich wenn ihr
auch beim nächsten mal wieder
einschaltet kommen haben sei es gut dass
probieren
naja ich hoffe das ist nicht aufgefallen
ist
nach der weisheitszahn op habe ich mir
das verdient und ihr euch auch wenn sich
die weisheitszähne ziehen lassen hat hat
hier schon mein beileid
danke schiff bis zum nächsten mal
[Musik]
die arme du wirst dich wundern dass
tolles feeling haben wir müssen aber los
für die karibik die schöne frische
früchte tolles wetter draußen vor dir
eigentlich stimmt
[Musik]